so this is going to be one of the
coolest Batman stories that DC's ever
done I can't wait till you guys get to
the end because that's going to be crazy
but what this does is this follows hot
off the heels of the whole Fail-Safe
story right so basically the robot that
Batman built in order to destroy Batman
and presumably the rest of the Justice
League if for whatever reason Batman
killed someone was out of control and
the Justice League tried to stop the
Fail-Safe robot so at the end of that
story Fail-Safe had basically shot
Batman but much like we saw in Grant
Morrison's final crisis instead of
Batman dying because he's too popular to
kill off they basically send him to an
alternate reality and this reality is
amazing so as soon as he gets here one
of the first things that happens is he
starts hallucinating basically Jim
Gordon who kind of looks like Mr Bones
in DC honestly he's not really important
here what is important is that things
jump to an apartment complex and this
version of Gotham where you have a guy
who looks like a Titan from Resident
Evil 2 because I'm playing through that
game right now and basically he smashes
down the door and keeps talking about
judgment now when he walks in here what
are he does is he asks the people in
this place I have one question are you
sane or are you insane because those are
the only two forms of judgment that
Gotham recognizes the only two things
there is a third one which is death for
anybody out there that challenges my
judgment but this guy kind of moves
around without any real oversight
whatsoever at least that seems to be the
case he's kind of the judge jury and
executioner now Bruce Wayne making his
way through here and realizing
somebody's calling for help because they
just happen to be near the rooftop that
he was at he immediately jumps in and
starts fighting this guy but what he
starts to realize is that one this is
Harvey Dent in this universe in the main
DC Universe he's normally two-faced he
got his origin story in the the long
Halloween in this universe he's not he's
just Harvey Dent who went from somehow
being a district attorney to becoming
like this almost villainous character
called the judge the other part of this
is that Harvey Dent is all hopped up on
the Venom formula right for those of you
guys who aren't familiar with that the
Venom Serum is what Bane takes in order
to amplify himself up and make himself
bigger stronger and more durable
apparently Bane doesn't exist in this
universe but instead what you have is
Harvey Dent who's walking around with
the serum and to a degree playing the
same role right chip sidarski is very
much basing this version of Harvey Dent
off of Dane from Tom King's Batman run
they're very similar in that way but of
course Bruce Wayne being aware of how to
defeat Bane despite his size is able to
get the upper hand on Harvey Dent and
then in turn like Firefly shows up who's
always a right it's one literally
in the story Bruce Wayne's like Firefly
is an idiot no matter what Universe he's
in because he opens fire in a wood
apartment complex he literally with a
flamethrower it's the dumbest possible
thing that you could do right it's
walking into a mine full of methane gas
and lighting a lighter in order to see
right you're gonna blow yourself and the
mind to Smithereens right it's literally
what's gonna happen so Bruce Wayne's
able to save the Innocence here but in
the middle of this fight he suddenly
rescued by this girl who just kind of
jumps in and whisks him away now while
this happens what we do is we jump over
to this reality's version of Catwoman
now the reason why chip sidarski is
likely using her as opposed to anybody
else is because Catwoman despite the
fact that her and Bruce Wayne aren't
technically married or really even in a
relationship there's still a lot of love
there from the work that was done during
Tom King's run when they were close to
being married so showing us this
alternate reality version is really
fascinating because what she's doing is
she's dealing with a henchman who had
basically been skimming off the top with
the money that he had was supposed to be
bringing to her now the funny thing here
she doesn't really care that he's been
skimming she cares that he's been
bragging which makes her look weak but
in the middle of the whole thing when
she's probably gonna kill this guy she
gets a call from a guy by the name of
the red mask do not let this guy's
initial indication walking through
Arkham people in chairs all that kind of
stuff do not let that put you off to
whether or not this guy is relevant he
is one of the coolest villains that DC's
introduced he's phenomenal and I
guarantee you're gonna love this guy now
once Bruce Wayne wakes up and really
kind of starts spilling the beans on
what seems to be going on he starts
talking about the idea that he's
hallucinating he's seeing things that
aren't necessarily there specifically in
relation to Jimbo that he feels fuzzy
and a lot of it just appears to be due
to multiversal travel right the fact
that he's just kind of been shot from
one Universe to another but what jewel
tells him is that it's not actually a
result of multiversal travel there is a
substance that's being pumped throughout
the city of Gotham in a gaseous form
that basically drives people to
hallucinate or to commit crimes
different things like that and so what
she says is that whole process is
basically being undertaken by a guy
named Darwin Halliday and she says the
only people who were not influenced by
that gas are the people who live in
what's called Athena Tower but of course
Bruce Wayne ever the detective is trying
to get to the bottom of one what
happened to this universe's version of
Bruce Wayne two what's going on in this
city and three since he's stuck here is
it possible for him to fix it and so
what he does is he literally tells Jewel
find a way to get me into Athena tower
now the funny thing about this is Jewel
tells him I can make you look the part
the question to ask here Bruce Wayne is
can you pretend to be rich now of course
yes he can he does it all the time he's
a billionaire in his own Universe it's
one of the coolest elements of Bruce but
the important thing here is that giving
him the tools he needs he's able to go
in there and just improvise now as he
makes his way to this party and he's
able to just kind of pretend to be super
rich and so on and so forth he starts
asking people questions about Darwin
holiday not only that he's unfamiliar to
them and so when they start asking him
questions like are you not an Athena
resident do you not live here in Athena
Tower his response is no like I'm
actually from out of town I'm new here
I'm basically trying to figure out where
it is that I want to be at Athena Tower
seems like the place to be right so one
part admitting that he's basically new
to the area and then the other part kind
of ingratiating himself to a degree or
flattering the ultra Rich because if
there's anything super rich people like
it's other people telling them how
awesome they are and so what ends up
happening is that Selena Kyle ends up
embracing him right like encounter
altering him and embracing him and it's
really really awesome because while she
doesn't say it right off the bat she
basically seems to figure out like that
that is Bruce Wayne she seems to figure
it out so incredibly fast and that's one
of the cool things is because what he
does is that in realizing it's Selena
and that she's basically a villain
essentially in this universe he almost
kind of sees her as the Selena from his
own universe and that's why he starts
saying things like have you ever wanted
something like a fresh start you ever
wanted to like leave and start your life
over again or something along those
lines and subtly putting out there this
idea that she could leave Gotham City
behind and they could run away together
and that kind of a thing right it's kind
of his emotions catching up to him but
what ends up happening is that he
ultimately ends up seeing Darwin holiday
for a brief moment up in the rafters and
when he does he immediately recognizes
him as the Joker and so what do you like
literally Batman's like okay I need to
leave and that's when Selena Kyle
snatches him up with her own Whip and
says I know you're Bruce Wayne and the
the whole thing was a track because
suddenly all these forces just come
descending onto Bruce Wayne now the
party itself was legit it was an actual
legit party being put on by the super
rich but as soon as they realized that
Bruce Wayne was there they were
literally mobilizing forces outside of
the building and bringing them all to
this location now Bruce is able to hold
his own against them for the most part
to a degree and in fact he is able to
engineer his escape the problem with
this and what's kind of nuts is that he
sees Alfred penny worth now Alfred is in
this universe and Alfred seemingly is
the one who inherited the entirety of
the Wayne Family Estate and so he is
ultra rich but he's also kind of a
coward he's not the Alfred that we're
traditionally used to which is the guy
that will do whatever it takes in order
to ensure the right thing gets done and
so it's a really really cool moment
because Batman basically jumps out of
the entirety of the building now the
funny thing about this is that when he
makes his jump there's this kind of
crazy Mueller right like he throws a
rope and then like he just kind of uses
it to sort of brace his fall right he
like flies down through like the ceiling
of a building and crash lands on the
ground and he's like I can do this
because I fell from the Moon and
survived so like chip zadarski's just
kind of having fun here if we're being
honest with ourselves and I love it is
it over the top and ridiculous yes but
it's also amazing at the same time and
so as a result of this Bruce Wayne comes
to this realization that with the world
realizing that Bruce Wayne is still very
much alive that is kind of history
repeating itself to a degree he realizes
Gotham City does not have a Batman and
so after beating up basically a cop who
is attacking a woman and kind of
clubbing her with a stick and God knows
what else he's going to do basically
chasing this cop off he is momentarily
kind of knocked down and then sees
basically a bat hanging upside down and
that's when it Dawns on him I need to
become this universe's version of Batman
and so when he does that it is a
makeshift Batman thing right he has none
of the tools and none of the resources
at his disposal it's just kind of him
doing his own thing but what's also nuts
here is you transition over to the
Riddler and one of the things that
happens here and one of the things to
know is that red mask within this city
of Gotham is basically the guy who runs
Arkham Asylum but one of the other
things that goes on and is actually
really really twisted is in this
reality's version of The Riddler that
what he does is he proposes these
riddles to little kids and if they're
not able to solve it they get sent out
to Arkham Asylum it's really messed up
it's twisted though what's nuts here is
that in the middle of all this suddenly
Batman arrives right and it's kind of
just an amazing moment because he
doesn't look like Batman the way he
normally does it's none of the posture
circumstance or anything like that right
it's just him and what is an effect a
makeshift Batman suit which is pretty
basic now one of the cool things is that
he's going to get a wholly new suit and
his new suit is going to be influenced
by a person that you least suspect now
what ends up happening here of course
with a riddler being beaten within an
inch of his life that Selena Kyle also
failed to capture Batman and so
basically the red mask seemingly using
like super speed feed which is kind of
nuts attack Selena Kyle and then tells
her if you do not find Batman I will
leave I will bring you into Arkham
Asylum you will be here and you will be
among all these people in here who are
being tortured full of torment all that
kind of stuff and so following that
after the defeat of the Riddler Batman
goes to visit the grave of Bruce Wayne
in this reality and the image of the
Joker haunts his face because what he
needs to know is he needs to know what's
going on like why is the Joker here but
not here at the same time why is this
guy seemingly Darwin holiday walking
around looking like the Joker at least
in terms of physical features but he's
not actually the Joker and so with
Batman digging up the grave of Bruce he
starts to realize that there's something
bigger going on here he seems to have
been killed but the question is how now
of course this leads to Alfred penny
worth stepping up basically like
wondering what in the world Batman's
doing here digging up the grave of Bruce
Wayne but the response of Bruce is like
I'm I'm basically this verse right but
I'm from a different reality and so what
ends up happening is that he basically
takes the body of Bruce essentially to a
hospital and with Jewel on the lookout
to make sure that nobody's showing up
here what he does is he actually
modifies the machine the MRI in order to
detect any traces of energy that
shouldn't be there and what he finds out
is that there are small traces of
multiversal energy here right this Bruce
Wayne seems to be a Bruce from
potentially another reality but before
we can even actually get any answer to
these questions you basically have the
judge Harvey Dent who shows up and then
starts like attacking everything right
attacking Bruce and so on and so forth
now it is a kind of final showdown
between the two but as much as like a
final showdown possibly can be because
in no uncertain terms this guy helps
Dent understand his place in the bigger
picture this fight doesn't even last a
hot second he absolutely crushes this
guy so what ends up happening is that
once the once Den is just beat within an
inch of his life once this guy's
absolutely pummeled and Wayne
establishes his dominance he ends up
meeting with Selena Kyle now the funny
thing about this is that Selena Kyle's
loyalties really to like red mask are
questionable at best and it's one of
those things that we just didn't really
know so she's not really loyal to
anybody now one of the things that kind
of is really interesting here is Bruce
Wayne tries to approach her as the
Selena that he knows which is that
person being an inherently good person
this Selena just kind of seems to be too
far gone down the dark side right down
the dark path and in fact she rejects
any attempted him to try to make the
case of like she's a good person she can
do good things but the whole reason for
her being here is she literally says I
can bring you to the red mask I can
bring you to this guy who runs the
entirety of of well like Gotham City I
can bring you to Arkham and tell you
what it is that you want to know now
Batman is no fool and he looks at this
and says okay so like this girl is
willing to lead me into the lion's den
and basically everything that she's ever
indicated to me is that she is a
straight up villain and as he's making
his way through Arkham one of the things
he sees is like Lex Luthor for example
is locked up in Arkham Asylum the flash
Barry Allen is locked up in Arkham
Asylum that's why there don't really
seem to be any superheroes on this earth
now the only reason why we make that
case is because the story doesn't really
explore anything outside of Gotham so we
don't know what Metropolis looks like we
don't know if like if Wonder Woman ever
left the Amazons like we don't know any
of that stuff right we're just kind of
hypothesizing here based on what we see
but Batman of course ends up coming face
to face with a red mask who removes his
helmet and then reveals he's actually
Darwin holiday right surprise surprise
I'm sure you guys already figured that
out here's what you didn't know and
here's what's gonna blow your mind right
it's gonna absolutely blow your mind so
what this guy does is he tells Batman
his story and he says that he at one
point just ran a pharmaceutical Empire
Gotham City was a city just like any
other and that's really all it was but
the idea here is that there was just
something missing in his life and he
didn't really know what it was so he
started pushing his staff members more
and more on these different experiments
and all kinds of crazy stuff until at
some point one of the compounds went
nuts and he halluced and sees into the
Multiverse and when he does he sees the
person he was supposed to become which
is the Joker he sees that like in any
number of alternate realities he became
the Joker he didn't become the person
that he is now and so what he's been
doing this entire time is trying to tap
into his own Insanity by understanding
the insanity of other people or at least
they're perceived Insanity so he can
become that insane character so he can
drive himself to be the Joker not only
that this is where things get cool the
residents of Arkham Asylum are not just
the citizens in Gotham right not just
people who were deemed insane by the
judge it's people from alternate
realities it's people from alternate
universes that what he was trying to do
is harness their multiversal energy and
in doing so feed that energy use that
energy and then become the Joker by
traveling into the Multiverse it's nuts
right it's it's just this crazy scheme
now one of the things that happens right
one of the cool things that goes on here
is that what DC has been doing is ever
since the end of Dark crisis they've
been building the Multiverse out this is
a return to DC Comics between like 1963
in the flash of Two Worlds technically
1961 and like the events of crisis on
infinite Earth in the 1980s during about
that 23-year stretch DC was crafting
stories like this where you would have
just crossovers with alternate realities
and like characters would just be
whisked off to alternate universes by
whatever Manner and whatever means it's
awesome to see DC doing this and so when
it comes to the realization that what he
intends to do is take all this kind of
multiversal energy right in the form of
like a gas pump it out into the city of
Gotham and then feed on all the
multiversal energy that will basically
be imbued within the citizens of Gotham
themselves that in turn accessing the
Multiverse would be the name of the game
that you have Bruce who reaches out to
Selena and says this guy's gonna kill
the entirety of Gotham in an attempt to
basically get into the Multiverse and
just create some crazy or find some
crazy version of himself now along the
way what you end up having is basically
ghost maker ghost maker was a character
that was introduced in Jim James
tinyon's run he and Batman trained
together when they were younger and the
overall difference between these two
characters is that of course Batman
doesn't really believe in killing right
he will put you in a place where
physically and mentally your life is
worse than death and you might be better
off dead as far as you're concerned but
at least he didn't kill you right I mean
that's kind of Batman's thing right the
ghost maker doesn't care about any of
that stuff the ghost maker will kill
criminals on the spot this reality
version is a little different he's
called the ghost breaker he's pretty
ruthless pretty hardcore he's like the
deadliest assassin that the red mask has
he's only ever sent out in the most dire
of circumstances in the fight between
ghost breaker and Batman that Batman
literally goes to kind of try to make an
escape and ghostbreaker in that moment
throws his sword and cuts off Batman's
hand which is kind of nuts not only that
in this reality is a rogue Superman from
some alternate universe to show showed
up here and was immediately overtaken by
the red mask and so now he just kind of
operates as a henchman of the red mask
as kind of a Mindless Beast now in one
of the most batman-esque moments ever
chip zadarski has this moment where
Batman just recites to Clark Kent I walk
as a man but I am your nightmare which
seems to like trigger this kind of just
reaction to Superman that just sends him
freaking out and just flying away but
again with Batman's hand basically cut
off by ghost maker now you got a
one-handed Batman who's running around
trying to find a way to like stop ghost
maker before everything can pop off
right before everything can go nuts now
the other part of this is that red mask
seemingly has a backup plan for a backup
plan because in the case that
ghostbreaker was killed by this version
of Bruce that what he also had or what
are called the leather wings now the
leather wings are basically just this
reality's version of Kirk langstrom also
known as manbat in DC Comics now again
all this is just stop Gap measure stuff
that's really all this is I mean these
are things that that red mask is sitting
out there are really to attack Gotham
more than anything else in the hopes
that it might keep Batman distracted
fortunately between Jewel and Alfred
pennyworth who finally grew some balls
along with Leslie Tompkins who is still
kind of the romantic interest of Alfred
albeit she kind of lost respect for him
because he's too much of a coward
between all of them working together
they are able to get a lot of the
citizens of Gotham inside of Athena
Tower before they're all subjected to
the crazy you know substances out there
now enough people are subjected to it
that red mask is able to feed off the
multiversal energy which Powers the
machine in order to try to turn himself
into the Joker but when this happens
this is one of the coolest Revelations
ever when this happens and he uses the
machine what he realizes is that he
cannot become the Joker instead him
using the machine and looking into the
Multiverse is actually him creating the
Jokers he's the reason why the Jokers
exist now for the most part when it
comes to how chip zadarski explains this
it's not overly well done and in fact
it's even still a little bit ambiguous
what it really seems to do though is it
seems to build on the idea of the
killing joke right this notion that
every single time there is an instance
where the Joker becomes the Joker that
The Killing Joke seems to be the origin
right like one bad day and it just
breaks him on a mental level when he's
thrown into the vat of chemicals at Ace
chemical by Batman inadvertently and so
once he comes out and he looks down into
the puddle in The Killing Joke just like
he seemingly always does that basically
the red mask looks in from the
Multiverse and sees the Joker becoming
the Joker and it seems to be based off
the reflection of red mask that the
Joker becomes Joker in the first place
so again we don't necessarily know again
it's not overly explained it's simply
just him coming to this realization that
he's the one that creates The Jokers
he's the reason why they exist and so
once Batman re-emerges onto the scene in
kind of an initial fight breaks out
between red mask and Batman himself this
is this is where it goes this is the
ending I was telling you about this is
where he goes nuts when the fight breaks
down once red Mass realizes he can't
beat Batman he takes off into the
Multiverse and what happens is basically
a cat and mouse game that you
essentially have Batman who jumps into
the Multiverse and goes after red mask
and as this happens he's transported to
all these different realities the first
reality he's transported to is Batman 89
Michael Keaton's Batman now those of you
guys who know from the movie The Joker
Jack Nicholson's Joker he died at the
end what ends up happening is the Joker
has returned seemingly because the red
mask brought him back to life and so
while he does meet with Michael Keaton's
Batman for a brief moment before any
real conversation can be had he's
literally pulled back into the
Multiverse again and at that point he
just kind of starts slingshotting around
different universes he ends up traveling
into the Batman the Animated Series
universe and basically fights alongside
that version of Batman against the Joker
who's basically returned although I
wasn't even aware that version of Joker
died in the first place he ends up being
transported to like the Snyder write
what passed for a decent set of DC films
that everywhere red Mass goes the jokers
in these universes that are supposed to
be dead end up resurfacing he ends up in
the Batman Beyond Universe fighting
alongside Terry McGinnis he sees like
this grizzled old version of himself and
in fact this version of Bruce Wayne
actually figured out that this version
of verse is from a different Universe
not only that that the red mask is
basically traveling throughout the
Multiverse and bringing Jokers back go
figure right an old grizzled Bruce Wayne
would figure out what's going on before
the main DC Universe Bruce Wayne ever
even showed up but it is cool and this
is kind of like this amazing encounter
between the two because as far as I'm
aware the main DC Universe Bruce Wayne
has never met his old grizzled self from
Batman Beyond I could be wrong and feel
free to leave a comment if I am but I'm
not aware of this ever happening so it
is just like a really amazing encounter
between them but as most people know
from the Batman Beyond universe that you
did have the original Joker that joker
was killed that joker reached turn in
the body of Tim Drake so seemingly that
version of Joker is back again right Tim
Drake Joker Is Back following this it's
Batman basically ending up in like the
Kingdom Come reality which is absolutely
amazing and then he ultimately ends up
coming across Batman in the Adam West
Universe now this is the crazy thing
here because when he gets here in the
conflict between the two of them when
the Joker's being dealt with pretty
quickly right with uh special effects
and word balloons and all that kind of
stuff as you would normally expect with
Adam West that what he actually ends up
doing is taking off his utility belt and
giving it to Batman as a kind of form of
assistance and so when you have Batman
from the main DC Universe who jumps to
the next Universe which is basically The
Dark Knight reality from Frank Miller
right The Dark Knight Returns when he
ends up in that reality of course he
comes across that version of Bruce and
as the two of them are talking that
version of Bruce ends up handing him
basically a kind of outfit of sorts or
at least a cape and a cow and so between
these different versions of Batman from
across the Multiverse you basically have
Bruce Wayne himself putting together a
kind of hodgepodge Batman suit it's a
multiversal Batman suit and it's dope
like it's really really amazing and so
with this being the case the final place
that he ends up finding red mask is
seemingly at the very end of the
Multiverse when you have what is quite
possibly one of the most horrifying
things in existence a whole bunch of
basically jokerized Megalodon sharks
that are eating reality it sounds cool
and I'd love to see it in a game or a
movie but it just sounds horrifying at
the same time but of course ever the guy
who's prepared for this anybody as soon
as you guys saw the the Adam West Batman
you had to know this was coming right
like Batman reaches into the utility
belt given to him by Adam West and pulls
out the one thing that we all know can
defeat sharks right the shark repellent
bat spray
which I absolutely love any of you guys
who never saw that from the Adam West
Batman movie it was hilarious literally
there's a shark on Batman's leg and he's
like Robin grab this shark repellent bat
spray so Robin gets out of his seat in
the helicopter grabs the shark repellent
bat spray brings it out and throws it
down to Batman who's phrased the shark
and the shark leaves and so following
that basically Batman beats the crap out
of red mask and he's ultimately defeated
right Batman kind of saves the day but
not before all these different versions
of the Joker from across the Multiverse
that were supposed to have been
destroyed end up coming back to life as
a result of the red mask which basically
allows DC to return to telling stories
about those versions of the Joker
without having to answer the question in
any complex terms how in the world they
managed to come back they can just point
to this story and that's effectively it
but in the midst of all this of course
Robin shows up basically rescues Batman
at the edge of the Multiverse brings him
back to the main DC Universe and the
days saved but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace